-Our next guest
is a Grammy-winning musician
and a founding member
of The Roots,
whom you can see every night
on "The Tonight Show."
His fantastic documentary,
"Summer of Soul
(...Or, When the Revolutio
Could Not Be Televised),"
is in theaters and on Hulu now
Let's take a look.
-It was the ultimate
Black barbecue.
And then,
you start to hear music.
♪♪♪♪
And someone's speaking.
-For the first time
in Harlem, Soulville, USA...
-And you knew
it was something bigger.
-Ladies and gentleman,
The 5th Dimension!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ Don'tcha hear me ♪♪
♪♪ Calling to you ♪♪
♪♪ Don'tcha hear me
calling to you, baby ♪♪
-Please welcome back to
the show, our friend, Questlove.
♪♪♪♪
-Hi.
How you doing?
-Good to see you, my friend.
-Great to see you.
Great to see you.
Great to -- No, hold your
applause, everyone.
[ Laughter ]
Hold your applause.
-Oh, yeah, you guys are spoiled.
You got an audience
and everything downstairs.
-You know what, though?
I -- I --
You know, I've been
a longtime fan of this show.
This was, like, the last thing
in the last normal...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-...whatever you want
to call it,
this is the last thing I did
before I realized how seriou
the next 16 months
was going to be.
But I -- I got to say,
I love the rhythm.
I like --
This feels like public access.
I like it.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God, thank you!
Well, I hope our -- our NB
paymasters are watching.
-Yes.
-And hearing that this is
a public-access show.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I love the rhythm of it
-Thank you, thank you.
We do love it, too.
So this is a wonderful fil
about the 1969
Harlem Cultural Festival.
This is not something
I knew about.
-Right.
-And --
-Me neither.
-That's the shocking thing
right?
Like, you have
all this knowledge of,
especially music history, an
when you first got word of this,
you also
didn't think it was real.
-I thought I had
all the knowledge in the world
You know, 'cause,
you know, I was --
There was a period where, like
I was the guy -- I was YouTube
I was the guy
that everyone called on
for any sort of archive.
So, naturally, when I --
You know, when they requeste
a meeting with me,
you know, I googled and I called
a few music experts,
and none of them
ever heard of this thing.
So I was very, very --
They hate when I say this,
but I -- you know,
I thought they just -- like,
"Why don't they just ask
for 'Fallon' tickets?
Like, it's easier."
-These were -- these were --
When you say this, these are
guys who are calling you,
saying, "We have this footage,
and we want you to see it.
-My two producers,
David Dinerstein
and Robert Fyvolent,
they said that they had
over 40 hours
of this mythical Stevie Wonder
Sly and the Family Stone concert
that happened in Harlem.
And, you know,
after like nine people told me
"I never heard of it,"
and they were like of age,
at the time,
I just, like, "Nah.
There's no way this happened."
-And so, I mean, it must hav
been, for someone like you
and for the kind of artist
that are in this film,
and what was it like
when you first sat down
and started watching
this footage?
Was it like the Holy Grail
-It's --
It's past the Holy Grail.
Like, this is what they call
lightning in a bottle.
And then, like, all my arrogance
sort of dissipated,
and suddenly, like,
I -- I became worried.
Like, why would they even
trust me to tell this story?
Like, a first-time storyteller
So, yeah.
I'll -- I'll just say that
I realized that I had, like,
the most valuable --
I'm sorry.
Am I giving my bracket awa
if I say the word "vase"?
-No, go for it.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry.
"Vayse."
You know, I knew I had an
important artifact in my hand.
So, the first thing I did was,
you know, I assembled
a crack team of experts.
-Mm-hmm.
-Shout-out to my producer,
Joseph Patel,
and my editor Josh, you know
And, you know, everyone else
involved with the project.
But, um, I -- I just wante
to do it because, you know
I'm an obsessive
for history, and so...
-Yeah.
And it's interesting.
You know, it seemed like
it was not just lost,
in that people
didn't know what happened,
but it seemed like
some of the people you talked to
that even performed at it,
almost, to some degree,
had forgotten.
'Cause we have this great thin
in the film,
which is you show -- we get to
watch people in real-time
watch their old performances
-Very meta. Yeah.
It's -- It's sort of that
"Harry Met Sally" situatio
where you get to reflect
and watch people
watch themselves.
I thought it was important
only because,
just in my research, I had s
many goose-bump moments of like,
"Wow, wow, wow!",
that sort of thing,
that I wanted them to have
the same response, too.
I wanted to catch their -- their
reaction when they first saw it.
And, yeah, it was complete -
Like, magic constantly
jumps from the screen
when you watch
these performances.
-And another magic thing
that's happened for you
is that some people
have reached out and said
they not only have seen
themselves in the footage,
they've seen, you know,
departed family members.
-Yeah. That --
That, to me, is my favorite part
of this whole process.
Um, all throughout social media,
like, every day, there's a -
a guy who hasn't seen
or has any photos of his brother
who passed away
when he was like 20,
like, during like 1970, '71,
and we have a close-up of them
So, like, the whole family
is like, you know,
they get their opportunity t
see their uncle as a teenager.
There's a woman that discovere
her great-grandmother
in the front row,
screaming at Stevie Wonder
You know, and daily,
I get things of,
"Oh, that's me when I was 14!"
You know?
So that's -- that's what's
happening right now. Yeah.
-Um, you had actually seen
footage of this before,
but you didn't know
what it was for.
You were in Japan.
-Yeah.
-And where did you see it?
-Okay.
So, when The Roots
first went to Japan, in 1997
back when things
were, like, more localized
and the Internet didn't connec
the world at the same time
um, if you wanted to see
anything from my childhood
old games, toys, artifacts
afro pics, whatever,
you went to Tokyo.
-Really?
-Because, I mean,
they have such an affinity
for, like,
'70s culture over there.
And so, my translator looked
at my afro and was like --
She kind of put two and tw
together like, "You know,
you remind me of Don Cornelius
from 'Soul Train,'"
and so, I was like, "Okay.
And then, she took me to a place
called the Soul Train Café
which is basically
kind of like a Friday's...
[ Laughter ]
...with better fonts.
-Yeah.
-And there was, like, monitors
all over the restaurant,
and I just happened to see
maybe a two- or three-minute
clip of Sly and the Family Stone
from one of
the far-away cameras.
And so, at the time,
I didn't realize I was watchin
the Harlem Cultural Festival
I thought it was like
Montreux Jazz Festival
or something, like, in Europe.
-And you -- I want to refer back
to something you said
about how
you used to be YouTube.
You took this very seriously
You carried around, like,
bags full of tapes, becaus
people had this expectation...
-Yeah.
-...that even when you traveled,
they could ask you
for this sort of piece of arcana
that no one else could get
-So I had two Kipling bags
probably the size
of this couch right here.
-Uh-huh.
-And then, once I went
to the Soul Train Café --
you know, again,
this is before the Internet,
before you can
instantly look at -- back at
something from your childhood.
All I have
are memories at that point
And so,
I asked this woman, like,
"Where can I find,
like, these clips?
You talk about 'Soul Train.'
I haven't seen that in 25 years.
Like, where is it?"
And, um, she took me to this
magical, like,
Video City in Tokyo.
And I stayed an extra two days
Like, I probably purchased
easily like $15,000 worth of -
-That's vase --
That's vase money.
-Yeah, vase money.
Yeah, getting it back into
the States
was a little bit weird.
But every --
from 1997 to about 2004,
if you saw me
in the streets of New York
I didn't have a backpack on.
I had two giant Kipling case
that I took with me everywhere
And this is what --
Like, when I worked on, like
Erykah Badu's record
or D'Angelo's record
or Common's album
or any artist I worked with,
we'd spend five hours
just going through
what we call, like, the treats
And that's how we made,
like, the records
that I'm sort of
associated with and known for.
Like, it's just based on that.
And then, YouTube came
and put me out of business
[ Laughter ]
So...
-You -- You also mentioned
going to Japan for festivals
Obviously, this is -- you know
it's a film about a festival
-Yeah.
-And The Roots were
a festival act for a long time
-The Roots Picnic, yeah.
-And what was it that drew
you guys to festivals?
Were you just -- you know,
were you building a fan base
Like, is that what the festivals
helped you do?
-So, the whole goal
of festivals,
especially when you're new
at going to Europe,
you want to do
the summer circuit.
It's fishing.
And, so, like, back in '92
if we're playing like
Reading Festival or Glastonbury,
behind -- you know,
they're waiting for Jamiroquai
to come on, and let The Root
do their 45 minutes.
You want to make an impression
So our whole goal was always
like, to lease -- "Okay,
there's 40,000 people out there,
but we just need 5,000 people.
And then,
you come back in December.
And when
you play clubs and theaters,
those people that saw you
at festivals,
there are your new fans.
-That's --
And what a cool thing to hav
gone through and done.
And this is really --
Congrats on this film.
-Thank you.
-"New Yorker" has already
called it
best movie of the year.
I mean, you couldn't
have expected, right?
-You know, this was --
this was my -- my -- my pivo
in pandemic sort of thing
that just kept me sane.
You know?
-Yeah.
-While we were waiting
for what was happening.
But I didn't realize that what
was my passion project would -
would even resonate
with the world like this.
So I'm -- I'm very excited
-Well, it's really special
I can't recommend it enoug
to everybody.
Thanks so much for being here,
my friend.
"Summer of Soul"
is in theaters and on Hulu now